[Music]
my name is AAL I'm the co-founder and
managing partner of Entre Capital we're
a venture capital firm uh I'm based in
Tel Aviv and we have officers in uh
London Tel Aviv and New York we're not
firsttime investors we've uh been doing
this for many years and um I think that
our own personal experiences
have given us an a certain view of the
world and a view of how we would like to
run our businesses and we try to impart
that knowledge to the founders and and
those that um we work together with and
uh uh we hope that that makes a
difference to them my background is uh I
came from a lower middle class family um
I uh had to pay my way through college
and and before um I started my first
business when I went to un University
and studied engineering um and I used
that to pay my way through University
and and I think that that's kind of uh
you know the the background that I've
had and the way that I've worked and
always uh been hungry and I think uh
that's what we try to do at entree when
we meet Founders we we don't believe
believe in a in a pitch we believe in a
process um and getting to know each
other um we look towards people that we
want to be comfortable working with over
a longer period of time and and again we
prefer directness we prefer um folks
that have a interesting story where
things where they've overcome a certain
uh hardship or they've worked their way
um into a position or or to a solution
um and to an opportunity we feel that
our biggest successes are the businesses
that we've been in the longest uh and so
it's it's a a marriage that one needs to
work at and so a lot of the meetings and
the way um the founders answer the
questions and the level of honesty and
thoughtfulness they put into it um will
get us to a fair amount of comfort 20
years ago when I was raising money for
my companies it was very old school
approach very Investment Banking type
driven a decade ago when we we started
on Tre Capital um it was um driven by an
understanding of the technology in depth
and what could be imagination and things
like that but still very much tied to
that um
investment uh traditional way of
evaluating companies and and
understanding them and I feel that in
the last couple of years the pendulum
has swung probably a bit too far into
into the imagination and into the every
business is a unicorn every business uh
can be huge and and and I think that
folks with less experience came into uh
the market and I think it betrayed some
of the fundamentals that existed 10 or
20 years ago and and and and in the last
year or two I think a lot of that's
returned um and and it is a
generalization and there were firms on
both sides uh SP extremes of of this
this argument but I think that the that
what we'll see is fewer Venture firms
over the next 10 years with um a lot
more due diligence and a lot more
expectation of uh financial and and and
other
business-driven uh metrics at an earlier
stage I think uh October 7th was
a tragedy literally a genocide and and
and in many respects a wakeup call not
just for Israel but for the rest of the
world as regards our fund specifically
um I I'm I'm I'm extremely grateful for
the the people that we have around us
who stepped up um above and beyond um
some people were drafted uh some folks
uh undertook uh unbelievable volunteer
projects uh we've all worked double
hours to um help our portfolio um to
deal with where there's been tragedy to
deal with those folks who've been
affected and uh I think we've all
contributed and feel like we even though
we've done a lot like everyone else
everyone feels they should do more by
and large I think it's um it's a small
event in you know the next five Decades
of of uh of companies and inventing and
and everything else but I think it's
it's been a big wake up call and I think
it's mobilized and um brought Israel as
a as a as a ecosystem and and by and
large Israel as a country uh back
together again about in conversation of
its values and and and what they want
what the country
needs thank you uh for for including me
in the list um a number of times now and
it's a nice reward for our firm to know
that the work that we all do together
results in um uh some recognition and we
we feel that um it's it's an opportunity
that certainly in this year and at this
time
that Israel is on the map and that as a
venture firm which is rooted in Israel
uh we can do and and do continue to do
business both in Israel and outside
Israel and that even in the darkest
times there's you know there's a ray of
light and hopefully we can take this as
a as a signal um to other firms and to
other Founders to say there's a value
system and there's a a certain way of
doing things and and hopefully that will
get us our fair share of of
success